it's so funny I was just talking to
garcelle you completely made her dreams
come true I just met Julia Roberts she
said oh my God I need to find you a
boyfriend I'm invested in this and I
said I can die now like I don't even
need the boyfriend
she needs a boyfriend you got anyone in
mind no but I'm going to be thinking
about it all day it's so exciting to see
you here at history talks when you think
about your history what do you hope
people remember most
oh my gosh
I I don't think of myself in historical
terms I guess I think about my parents
when I think about my personal history
um and then just sort of coming up in a
time when there was an even greater
inequality of
what the man got and what the women got
so I feel like I I did a little bit
towards pioneering in that regard
we are so so excited about ticket to
Paradise I'm sure I'm sure you know that
oh come on you've got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am I need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worse 19
years of my life we were only married
for five I'm counting the recovery and I
like lovingly call it a Julia wrong
common sense because now we've got you
we've now got you back in the genre do
you feel like there are more rom-coms in
your future now that you've done ticket
to Paradise
I you know I have no there's no way of
knowing it really is it's a it's a
difficult genre to get right and to find
a good script so
um you know I'm always open and and
available I mean this one came about and
with George
um as my partner in it it was pretty
delicious and you can't escape the guy
you did a movie in covid you're on the
Press tour you're now here at history
talks what is it about that friendship
uh it's just really meaningful I think
we're both really uh devoted friends and
our lives have evolved kind of in
parallel and so now our families are
quite devoted to each other and yeah
it's really nice
foreign